can you share some of the stuff uh with
norm yeah yeah that you have a norm i
was just
he reached out he was a big uh
when people were going through it norm
was one of the guys that would always
reach out and uh yeah that was it just
reached out he sent me some cool stuff
about like
funny will win yeah that was the coolest
[ __ ] ever yeah yeah he was like there's
a war right i don't want to
i don't want to spill the beans on a
nice thing but it was like you guys had
a private thing yeah it was cool it
ended up supportive yeah he spoke like
poetically yeah it was awesome yeah and
it ended one of the messages ended with
like in a war for comedy i think the
ones with jokes will win it's just like
yo yeah that's fire nor macdonald is
king yeah yeah and he in no way has to
do that no you know what i mean to reach
out you know especially at that time i
thought was really cool it was two years
ago i mean
yeah as he's battling something no
disrespect way worse yeah yeah yeah
i mean he's like hey you need help i was
with adam eget most the time in austin
the guy you know adam yeah yeah from uh
from the store right yes yeah yeah so me
and adam went to the cowboys eagles game
and we were hanging out in the whole
the whole time because he that was he
was
best friends with norm yeah so he was
like going through it but he went
through it the same way as like
he we just talked like norm the whole
time like the whole game was like ah you
must have
yeah he got hit pretty hard you know
what's worse than getting hit like that
blood cancer
yeah it's no good that blood can't
just like that the whole time it was
great i hope that wasn't sharing too
much for adam yeah but yeah it was fun
norm's the best yeah it was but he died
of [ __ ] oh right i forgot he [ __ ]
vanished yeah
norm yeah classic
nah he's a [ __ ] man that was cool
yeah there's that [ __ ] passage man
from his book man i sent it to you you
read the book but i keep thinking about
that [ __ ]
yeah
it was awesome yeah
is this what manchester by the sea is
like
worse
way worse similar to that have you seen
it no no no no
never going to work it's actually worse
than blood cancer
[Laughter]
what happens in that movie is worse yeah
yes i'm not going to watch it ever
yeah you'll like it if you like uh all
the teenager movies you like you're
going to love this one why is that if
you have kids brain you're going to love
manchester by the city what is
do you think people think i'm dumber
than you exactly
you're banking on people buying into
right now i bet they know
i have faith but no just like you guys
are proving already a majority of the
people are dumb
majority of the people in the comments
will be like [ __ ] that [ __ ] avengers
is so good
fast and furious is my favorite movie
[ __ ] what is what is worse to
watch like teenager movies or teenagers
i love teens i love watching the teams
yes
i'll toss on avengers to pretend i'm you
know
we'll watch it together what do you like
like it's a tricky algorithm you're like
listen up phone
serve them up yes
too much football oh my god they do need
to stop serving up teens on the internet
they do it should be illegal huh yeah it
should be some yeah
because then but nobody's willing to
bring it up because then you have to be
the one to be like it's all it's hot
yeah
you're gonna be like what what's wrong
with a teenager dancing it's like
shouldn't you just be able to say don't
show me anything under 20. like just put
the [ __ ] i think tick tock started
good if you're under if you're using
they won't show you if you're under 18
or something like that i forget what the
protocol was perfect it was some some
type of inhibition and it should just be
on every single phone yeah
but then you have to have one person
that has to go through everything and
determine if it's sexual in nature don't
you have to put your
okay
don't you have to put the date though
for your uh your birthday yeah if you
don't play anything
here's a funny cow fact i don't want to
know i don't want to know i don't want
to know if you're 12. you don't need to
tell me anything you want to know about
count facts i'd love to know
this guy they have like three stomachs
or something
he loves cows dude that was eight but
yeah is it eight stomachs that's gone
down you should know you guys are
[ __ ] worshipping them
i like them you guys [ __ ] love them
dude yeah we do love them we love them
but not for their stomachs it's just you
like the guts
what do you like about them
the milk the cool horns the food
yeah
precisely
dude i think we really saved the pot man
we turned it around really i turned it
around
i don't know what to tell you i think
you take about an hour to warm up not he
needs that he needs the [ __ ] pokes he
needs a little poke he needs it too much
love up top he didn't know how to handle
it i didn't like that very much yeah
what did it make you feel like what does
it make me feel i don't know i don't
know you don't feel like you deserve it
or something that's what it is
i don't know because i do think the
special is good
i'm happy with it don't call yourself
the special okay
shane you're a good guy that was good
that was a good one
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude
you guys bring me down here to just
trash me this is this is hate on the
spectrum brothers
dude we tried giving you praise
you guys treat me like [ __ ] we tried
giving you praise ruining the podcast
listen he's lean forward but he's
jordan
he's
[Laughter]
so don't try to put that on me either it
was just one time i wish i had it it was
just one time
it was like that and his mouth was a
little bit more open really about
thornton's better sling blades better
than nic cage yeah actually billy bob
thorne beast yeah real beast you were
him for halloween one year weren't you
yep which character slingblade yep nice
could you do it yep
no
you do the voice yeah hi i'm billy bob
wait do you suck at him i've never ever
seen the movie he's gonna actually never
see him he's got an accent though yeah
but do australia
all right yeah yeah all right
all right
what accent i'm good at one now i can't
do english i can only do one of the
other oh yeah yeah yeah yeah it shuts
off for some reason i don't know why
yeah so go english hello mike no see now
i'm already it's a bit of a [ __ ]
problem in it
you can do cockney yeah because it's
different sure do refined english than
australian hold on i have to hear it
hello
i'm stewie i have to i can't do english
i have to do like a specific person or
you could do gypsy king or something
like that yeah
right no i don't think i can do it a
fake i think you spot about three in the
morning
i was over there about three in the
morning in the morning yeah
oh i could i could do irish for a second
i could do your face does the impression
mcgregor's kind of i used to be able to
do it go go go go go
oh hold on
uh i'd like to give me what's he talking
about i'd like to apologize absolutely
like to take this time to apologize to
absolutely nobody that's good
nobody nobody yeah yeah yeah yeah the
throat hey connor what are you doing
nate's the best go nate
you know [ __ ] that like this is easy
it's very slight lisp yeah yeah right
yeah yeah does it sound good yeah keep
going
you said two words shut up you try one
you do one you just sit here and
criticize criticize criticize one
impression
loretta divine over here i am sick and
tired of being sick and tired and chris
i got a good christmas let me see chris
rock i can hear it what do you want to
see my chris rock for yeah
you want me to dance for you
[Laughter]
just use it as an excuse to call people
i do a real good chris rock you [ __ ]
crackers
[Applause]